at least nine Palestinians were killed
during a protest at the Gaza border when
Israeli soldiers opened fire from the
Israeli side hundreds of others were
injured
it was the second large-scale
demonstration in a week
Jonathan Vigliotti is in our London
Bureau with the latest Jonathan good
morning good morning the protests
started as a build-up to the anniversary
of Israel's founding but they are
increasingly becoming an act of defiance
against what Palestinians are calling
Israel's violent effort to silence their
voices the volatile border was engulfed
by plumes of black smoke coming from
burning tires and atactic Palestinians
used Friday to block the view of Israeli
snipers for the second week in a row
thousands of Palestinians backed by
Hamas returned to the border to protest
against Israel's land blockade tensions
were high after the Israeli army shot
and killed 19 protesters last week in an
effort to reduce the bloodshed Hamas as
leader promised protesters would not be
armed with guns and the Israeli military
said they had no fight with genuine
protesters while there were no reports
of gunfire from the Palestinian side
yesterday Israeli troops did open fire
from across the border killing at least
nine and wounding nearly 500 others
among the Dead a well-known Palestinian
journalist the Israeli military said it
fired only on instigators involved in
attacks on soldiers or the border fence
and released this video they say shows a
Palestinian trying to break through the
United Nations has urged both sides to
avoid violence and said there were
strong indications that Israeli security
forces used excessive force last week in
driving protesters back a breach of
international law the protests are
expected to continue next week and every
week until May 15th the 70th anniversary
of Israel's founding and Amasa has
warned future protests could become more
violent
Ezreal has alleged Hamas is using the
protest as a
for attacking the border fence dana's so
far policy and wire cutters have proven
no match for assault rifles Jonathan
Vigliotti in London Thank You Jonathan